Street Fighter 6 is really really good
that's probably not a huge surprise to
you if you've been following fgc Twitter
for example but plenty of people play
Street Fighter 5 and checked out well
guess what it's time to check back in
because we've been playing Street
Fighter 6 for over a week and frankly
there's plenty of reason to believe that
it's the greatest Street Fighter game
ever especially if you're a first time
player
[Music]
so Street Fighter 6 is a really good
game as I've already said but what makes
something the best in its series well
why don't you try just making combat
both deep and interesting while at the
same time giving new players a great
spot to jump into the series obviously
fighting games are a pretty intimidating
genre but this one is doing so much to
both bring back old fans and bring in
people who may never have even thought
about taking a fighting game seriously
the big mechanical change for returning
players is the drive system which
basically gives you access to a bunch of
skills similar to ones from Old Street
Fighter games at the cost of Drive meter
Drive Impact is another new addition and
it's this big wound up armored attack
that helps you close the distance with
your opponent and break through their
armor while some people will say this
probably feels the most scrubby of the
new additions I think for a new fighting
game player something like this makes
kind of into would have sense in a way
that will help them approach the game
the most important thing about the drive
system is that you come into around with
basically all of your character's tools
instead of having to wait halfway
through the round for you to have been
beaten up enough to have your comeback
mechanic or whatever you choose how you
use those resources at the beginning of
the round one of the biggest complaints
about Street Fighter 5 was that it felt
like a round didn't really start until
someone lost half their life because
that's when they got their v-meter and
they had access to all these other fun
tools Street Fighter 6 just says here
you go here are the fun tools and do
what you want with them the characters
in this game have pretty big move lists
compared to other Street Fighter games
they feel pretty complex and they have
interesting variations on things that
you've come to expect it leads to a
really fast-paced game where characters
have a ton of crazy Combos and lots of
flexibility for each player to approach
them any way they want to basically it's
the exact opposite of Street Fighter 5
at least at launch now maybe you've
already caught on to the fact that I
both said that this game is new for
beginners but also that the move lists
are deep in fact maybe more complex than
any other Street Fighter game to date
we'll get to that in just a moment but
first off let's talk about modern
controls basically the new modern
control scheme removes all input
requirements from special moves so you
don't have to do a quarter Circle to
throw a fireball with Ryu anymore you
can just hit the special button kind of
like how special moves work in a game
like Smash Bros a lot of Hardcore
fighting game players are upset with the
ease of modern controls I guess but it
does have drawbacks you do less damage
overall and your options are just more
limited than somebody playing with
classic controls but you know what
having said that some Pro players are
experimenting with modern over classic I
think it's a sign that Capcom has really
made something special with modern
controls it won't be for everybody but
it's cool that you're not actually
handicapping yourself and that it's more
a different style of play one that will
make things much easier for new players
so new players will have this option
when they start playing which will let
them approach the game before feeling
like it's shutting them out while at the
same time if you're an old head you're
probably playing on you know a stick
maybe a fight hat or even just a normal
pad and you're gonna be using classic
controls you'll have all the flexibility
and options that you're used to it's a
good deal but that's not the only thing
that Capcom is doing for new players
there's an entire brand new single
player mode and I know what you're
thinking fighting game single player
modes but no this one is deep and it
helps new players learn about fighting
games listen if you've ever played a
single player mode in a fighting game
then I'm sure you're aware that
typically there just isn't much there
usually we're talking about some kind of
pseudo arcade mode sometimes with some
kind of cool gimmick thrown in like
think like Tekken 7's treasure hunt mode
for example but Street Fighter 6 has
this purpose-built single player mode
where you run around in open world and
learn how to play fighting games and
it's sweet the open-ended world tour
mode lets you design your own weird
fighter learn styles from Street Fighter
characters explore Metro City and then
start street fights with anyone willing
to throw down sure it's deeply really
unserious it's almost like Street
Fighter meets Yakuza in a sense like
spinning bird kick is a traversal tool
you can literally have a friendly fight
with the cops or someone enjoying their
Starbucks on the way to the office and
at night people with boxes on their
heads will literally attack you on site
but World Tour also acts as this no
pressure introduction of fighting games
by explaining these new modern controls
alongside poor fighting game Concepts
like canceling moves or overhead attacks
you also learn characters in a way by
adding their Styles and some of their
moves to your own and if World Tour does
succeed at getting a player to log into
the battle Hub and try playing against
other people while Capcom has made that
experience very good as well the move
list for characters in this game got a
massive glow up it shows you not only a
video of the move and its variations but
it also gives you some tips on how to
actually use it I know that sounds
obvious but most of the time the move
list was literally just the Imp puts and
the move name that's it you figure out
how to use it if you go even deeper and
consult the character guide for a
fighter you're interested in you get a
great surface level walkthrough so for a
new player the command list used to just
show the what now it also helps with the
how and the why but the character guide
also takes that responsibility away from
the player at least initially by
explaining a character's game plan and
how their moves fit into that for once
in my life I'd have No Reservations
telling a new player listen find a
character you think is cool and then
just complete their in-game character
guide because even if they don't learn a
ton about the actual process of playing
the character at least they will have
some inputs that they know are useful
that they know are kind of the go-to
things for this character World Tour and
the new player experience are probably a
little bigger than they strictly
speaking need to be but at the same time
it has such potential to bring in new
players that I can't help but love World
Tour for that fact alone and if along
the way I get to punch out a mime while
looking like Sam bankman freed well
that's even better but what's in store
for those new players who take advantage
of these tools that I just mentioned and
do finally make the jump to online well
I've got Sean to explain that to all you
fine folks
hey so there's one more important thing
to talk about and that's the net code so
unlike my colleagues I'm pretty much
exclusively an online Warrior I live
about two hours away from the closest
local and I interact with fighting games
more or less entirely online I've played
more Street Fighter 5 than any other
fighting game and if you're like me you
know that playing it online was pretty
awful sometimes and that came down to
the net code which connected you to your
opponents Japanese fighting games have a
history of kind of bad online play which
is why netcode has been one of the
biggest talking points in the fighting
game Community for years and I am so so
happy to report that in Street Fighter 6
the net code is [__] great so as I'm
recording this I've sunk about 27 hours
into the game that time has been spent
entirely in training mode combo trials
and playing online games and in all that
time I haven't had a single connection
that I consider unplayable if you spend
a lot of time on social social media
you've probably seen folks making a big
deal of the fact that some n a players
have been able to connect with Japan
pretty reliably so I decided to test
that out for myself I went into one of
the busiest Asian region lobbies and
played against two players with over 200
paying that were likely in or around
Japan and it was fine sure it was
noticeably worse than a local n a
connection but it was honestly better or
on par with anything that I would have
expected back in Street Fighter 5. my
opponents were hitting their Combos and
any combos that I managed to drop were a
skill problem not a game problem I
promise in five or six games I dropped
less than 10 frames to Japan that's not
good net code it's Witchcraft and back
home in n a three bar players with
around 70 ping that would have tormented
me back in five felt stable and playable
this is a huge deal for a scene that has
had to meet in person to play their
games seriously for deaf decades I'm so
excited that I can finally have real
online play but mostly I'm just happy
that I can mash my supers in peace
so there you have it we think Street
Fighter 6 is pretty great we've all been
playing it around the office some of us
have been focusing on different parts of
it but in the end we think there's a lot
to love and after a long era of people
being justifiably pretty down on Street
Fighter it feels good to have this new
game that's rallying the community in
ways that honestly
seemed implausible a few years ago if
you've never played a fighting game
before this is a perfect place for you
to start I'm not kidding and if you have
played and perhaps left because of
Street Fighter 5 listen they did a lot
to the game
I think you owe it a shot here
by the way play play World Tour just to
see the character intros for these
characters they're awesome like DJ's
literally just on a beach DJing you're
like I need to learn from you and he's
like all right here's how we dance and
you're like no I want to fight bro and
he's like okay like it's so good you're
you should try it that's all I'm saying
you should try